well
we did it ames we made the world's
hottest baby
say cute jake no this kid is liquid fire
crazy to think in just 17 short years
he's gonna be six foot seven in the
number one draft pick for the knicks
hmm and then he's gonna pass up that
opportunity to pursue his true passion
library sciences well the important
thing is we'll support him no matter
what
even if he's a huge huge nerd especially
then
are we gonna be okay at this i mean this
entire day felt like a warning from the
universe
i almost missed the birth we had our
baby at the precinct a firefighter
touched our child
we washed him off yeah but i'll always
know babe we talked about this
everyone balances working kids yeah but
everyone's not a cop
true but when our son wants to hear
about the day he was born
we get to tell him that his dad helped a
bunch of people
and foiled a bank robbery
i guess that is kind of cool and his mom
managed a city-wide emergency while
actually giving birth
i'm proud for her son to have you as a
dad
me too for you to be the mom
i was just agreeing with the nice thing
you said about me i love you
love you too oh my god he's beautiful
oh jake he's got your face charles
meet mac short for mclean i said surely
i love it no as in john from die hard
i mean they're both incredibly cool
there's only one oscar winner thanks for
getting jake there in time oh
don't thank me the real hero is
lieutenant peanut butter
no it was all you charles or should i
say
uncle chi-chi don't ruin the smell for
yourself uncle charles it is
how's he doing he's perfect i see you
changed oh yeah that other outfit had a
lot of after birth on it also
during birth and pre-birth the point is
i burned it thanks for staying by my
side
i know it wasn't easy for you it's worth
it i'm anti-railroad
she gets to be ro-ro incredible seven
years away for this
captain lieutenant the dance was great
and it really helped thank you dance
what dance
she doesn't know what she's talking
about mommy brain much captain holt and
i did a hip-hop dance routine
oh i see well you know what
i don't even care that i missed it
because right now i am holding
my son and there's nothing more
important in the world than that i have
a video if you want to see it amy hold
this baby give me that phone
give me that phone everyone wash your
hands
you